merci arnaud pour ce regard ce
témoignage ses propositions justement
sur les contrats l'espère les contrats
de plan état région
effectivement tu l'a souligné 70 % des
crédits sont affectés à des territoires
urbains
donc l'idée dans nos propositions c'est
un euro pour l'urbain 1 euro pour le
rural
voilà un principe de parité je vais
céder la parole est maintenant aux
directeurs de l'ordre des médecins la
santé vous le savez toutes et tous est
un problème de l'ordre des infirmiers
pardon la santé c'est un problème pour
nos territoires ruraux et nous avons là
avec l'ordre des infirmiers un exemple
intelligente d'un accord d'une
coopération qui a été mis en place et
qui permet de régler un certain nombre
de problèmes voilà monsieur directeur
oui de l'ordre des infirmiers
effectivement les infirmiers sont des
infirmières des acteurs du monde rural
par excellence il y a six cent mille
infirmiers en france est la plus grosse
professions de santé par le nombre et
100000 un peu plus 105000 exercent à
titre libéral
quarante mille 40 % de ces cent mille
exercent dans des communes rurales
donc les infirmières sont par excellence
donc un acteur de santé du milieu rural
et vous aviez juste titre soulevé madame
le fait que la santé est un élément clé
aujourd'hui de l'attractivité rural et
une demande très forte des personnes en
milieu rural qui à laquelle il faut
évidemment trouver des réponses
alors la profession infirmière est une
profession importante par le nom mais
elle est totalement liés à la profession
médicale
il y a foncièrement dans les soins
primaires parce que c'est de cela dont
on parle ils sont prom de proximité le
premier recours un binôme qui est le
binôme médecins infirmières et c'est
vrai que les infirmières ont depuis 2008
dans un cadre conventionnel pas ça n'a
pas été imposée c'était un accord entre
la profession et l'assurance maladie
consentis à certaines mesures de
conventionnement sélective c'est à dire
de limitation des installations
d'infirmières dans des zones jugées
comme étant sûr dotées en infirmier avec
un certain nombre de calculs faits sur
des ratios et le nombre de personnages
et c est avec d une politique
d'incitation à l'installation dans des
zones jugées
quant à elle sous dotées donc notamment
des zones rurales
ça a été mis en place en 2008 relancer
encore en 2011 et affiné c'est une
politique previn vous parliez des
bassins de vie ça se passe justement au
niveau des bassins de vie ces zones
ce sont les bassins de vie et elle a
permis cette politique de redouter 500
zones jugées sous-dotées qui sont
devenus ce qu'on appelle des zones
intermédiaires vers des zones où là pour
le coup il ya plus de mesures de
régulation parce que le ratio de
d'infirmiers est jugé suffisant au
regard de la population et de ses
besoins
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un problème je
vous le disais le binôme de prise en
charge des soins primaires ces médecins
et infirmiers et il aurait peut-être été
assez logique que parallèlement à la
mise en place de ces mesures concernant
les infirmiers il y a également une
réflexion pour les médecins certes les
éléments ne sont pas nécessairement tous
les mêmes
la profession infirmière est très
nombreuse encore une fois je les 10 mai
et puis c'est une profession prescrite
c'est à dire que essentiellement les
actes qui sont réalisés par les
infirmiers le sont prescrits par un
médecin a donc il faut bien quand même
la présence d'un médecin donc c'était
cet élément est fondamentale et une
approche qui serait davantage en terme
de deux groupes de binômes médecins
infirmiers à notre sens serait plus
source de réponse pour ces zones rurales
il faut aller plus loin néanmoins que
cela d'abord il faut que cette politique
elle soit faite sur la durée c'est très
important car il nous faut dans le champ
de la santé sas est fondamental c'est un
message important
il nous faut une certaine continuité
dans les politiques la loi hpst en 2009
avait mis en place un dispositif
intéressant qu'on appelle les pôles de
santé
hélas une nouvelle loi vous nous en
avait éventé évidemment entendu parler
la loi de modernisation de notre système
de santé veut les remplacer par un autre
concept voilà émanant d'un autre bord
politique
les communautés professionnelles de
territoire et encore avant ça s'appelle
les services territoriaux de santé au
public
une approche très technocratique des
choses dans lesquelles les
professionnels de santé se sont
absolument pas reconnu
quand un professionnel de santé une
infirmière elle est libérale c'est une
entreprise quelques reine lorsqu'elle va
s'installer dans une zone rurale le
médecin c'est pareil il a besoin d'une
visibilité à beaucoup plus long terme
que cinq ans c'est à dire l'arrivée de
la future loi de santé c'est pas
possible on a besoin vraiment on crée
une entreprise ont investi on a besoin
d'une visibilité à long terme ça c'est
un élément également fondamentale
donnons de la lisibilité de la stabilité
pour que les professionnels est envie
d'investir encore une fois les
infirmières elles vont s'installer en
milieu rural je voulais 10 40% de ses
infirmières son temps mais installée en
milieu rural et depuis 2010 entre 2010
et 2014 et 75% d'infirmières libérales
en plus en france donc ça montre bien
que c'est un domaine où on le sait il ya
des créations d'emplois ce et dynamique
il faut absolument stimule et cela
notamment par le biais de mesures de
convention qui peuvent aussi concerner
les médecins encore une fois c'est un
élément fondamental
je termine par un tout petit mot il y a
également une autre dimension qu'il faut
prendre en compte que les pays
scandinaves notamment ou le royaume uni
ont pris en compte dans l'évolution de
leur système de soins primaires c'est la
montée du niveaux des infirmières qui
ont peuvent avoir un rôle de premier
recours de tri même d'envoi vers le
médecin spécialiste
ça n'est absolument pas à l'encontre du
pouvoir des médecins ou de leur rôle qui
est évidemment celui du diagnostic qui
est fondamentale mais une infirmière
c'est le par définition un professionnel
qui a une vision très globale du patient
y compris sociales y compris de
coordination avec le monde médico-social
avec les services d'aidé ménagère à
domicile etc
et donc c'est fondamental de remonter le
niveau de certaines infirmières pas tout
à un niveau d expertise qui leur
permettra de remplir le rôle que peut
être dans certaines zones
les médecins ne peuvent plus remplir du
fait d'une démographie encore
défaillante et qui ne pourra pas
augmenter suffisamment dans un délai
court
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur le
directeur